ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
8私は学生です
道元学生じゃなくて学生です
日本語は基本的にフラットなんでわかりました
流暢になりたいんだったらや流暢じゃなくて
留鳥ですフラットだとさっき言いましたよね
それもフラットじゃなくてフラットです
ぷっ
フラットですかえ日本はフラットですか
フラットです
この先生皆さん映って感じ見たことありますか
てん
道元さんおめでとうございますそれでは出産費用な家は気を説明しますね
はいお願いします怖いな奥さんが1週間止まっていましたのでまずこれに右です
入ってこちらがその食事代はい次これ予防接種とオムツ代そしてさあ
を出産手術の費用ですはいまあですので保険を入れて計算しんもすとあーこえーな
15万円になります150,000円だけですかはい
ただしマジですかアメリカだと100万円以上かかるって聞いたことあるんでかなり
心配してました
道元さんこれはあなたが支払う金額ではありません
出産費
の合計と保険会社が負担してくれる金額の差額ですあああ
わかりますかいや分かりませんつまり15万円が余ったのでこれを保険会社は道元さん
に支払います
いや分かりませんしかし堂ゲーさんの場合は双子なので本当はこの倍近くなります
本当に訳してくれればと1週間以内に職場
からのお祝い金も振り込まれますのでご確認ください
いや分かりません
me